For most people, going to the movies is a
surefire form of stress relief one that's
specifically intended to distract us from
the turmoil of our own lives for a least an
hour or two.
Of course, that can occasionally backfire,
because some films just won't allow you to
switch off your brain and check out of the
world for even one single minute.
That's not always a bad thing, though.
In fact, some of the best films out there
are good simply because they challenge our
hearts and minds.
Here are some of the most stressful movies
you'll still want to watch.
Seven
When Seven made its way to theaters back in
the fall of 1995, the world was simply not
ready.
But David Fincher's relentlessly bleak symphony
of sorrows is still a masterpiece that continues
to serve as a bizarre, gory mirror for moral
and societal excesses.
The film opens on a dour note and only gets
more desolate, desperate, and stressful with
every moment that follows.
Still, Seven is so meticulously constructed,
obsessively executed, and skillfully acted
by its leads that even at its most gruesome
it's almost impossible not to want to watch
it all unfold.
"Awwww, what's in the box?
What's in the f------ box?"
Whether it's because of Seven's obsessive
nature, it remains one of the most rewatchable
movies ever made, no matter how difficult
it is.
mother!
Speaking of directors who like to push buttons,
Darren Aronofsky is another director known
to break boundaries.
But nothing in his riveting collection could've
prepared audiences for the brain-bomb that
was his 2017 offering, mother!
Set in a tranquil, secluded country home,
the film follows a struggling poet and his
young wife as they try to write and remodel
their home.
That peaceful existence is disturbed with
the arrival of unexpected guests, and things
quickly get out of hand.
As mother! propels itself to its shocking
but inevitable finale, the moments that lead
us there come with a constant, feverish upping
of the ante.
Watching mother! is an emotionally draining
affair, which might explain the movie's box
office problems.
But like the best of Aronofsky's films, the
anxiety and discomfort caused by watching
it is still totally worth it.
Buried
For much of his early career, the thought
of taking Ryan Reynolds seriously as an actor
just seemed laughable.
But many filmgoers' opinions of Reynolds as
an actor were forever changed after seeing
his nerve-wracking 2010 micro-budget thriller
Buried.
The whole film takes place in a coffin buried
somewhere in the Iraqi desert, and Reynolds
is the sole actor and yes, he's buried inside
the coffin.
If you're claustrophobic, sitting through
this movie is a lot like subjecting yourself
to a 95-minute anxiety attack.
And even if you're not afraid of enclosed
spaces, Buried is still tough to tangle with.
But if you can make it through the cramped
space of the film, it's a first-rate thriller
with a few clever twists, some surprisingly
insightful commentary, and an impressive dramatic
performance from Ryan Reynolds, who doesn't
snidely snicker or break the third wall even
once.
Under the Skin
Sometimes it's hard to pinpoint exactly what
it is about a movie that stresses you out,
but in the case of Jonathan Glazer's Under
the Skin, it's quite literally everything.
The film's photography, music, acting, sound
design, and editing are designed with the
single goal of keeping viewers on edge.
The result is a challenging, deeply disturbing
movie that you don't really watch as much
as you experience.
At the same time, though, it's also a profoundly
engaging, ambitious picture that hypnotizes
viewers into entering its darkness as it examines
complex topics of identity, extraterrestrial
morality, and what it means to be human.
At the center of that exploration is the single
weirdest, and possibly strongest, performance
of Scarlett Johansson's career.
The film works best if you know as little
as possible going in, but watchers should
be warned that if you feel uneasy while watching
the flick, that just means it's working.
Enemy
Denis Villeneuve's doppelgänger thriller
Enemy is adapted from a novel by experimental
novelist José Saramago and follows an average
man whose middling life is thrown into flux
when he spots his exact double in a movie.
What follows is a study of identity and modern
isolation that finds Jake Gyllenhaal in top
form playing dual roles, and Villeneuve beginning
to tease the daring style that has become
his trademark in the years since.
It's also worth noting that spiders figure
prominently in the film, which means there's
a fair amount of arachnid angst involved in
watching it.
More importantly, though, the film is also
rife with metaphorical webs that the director
uses to pull viewers further into the sticky,
deadly center.
Enemy is one of those rare movies that's distressing
enough just to watch, and even more so after
the credits have rolled and you're stuck trying
to figure out what the hell just happened.
Bug
William Friedkin directed one of the most
unnerving films ever made with 2006's Bug,
but odds are you've never heard of it.
Bug features one of the finest performances
of Ashley Judd's career and a breakout turn
from the great Michael Shannon.
Perhaps one of the reasons Bug hasn't quite
broken any box office records is that it's
hardly a feel-good affair.
The bulk of the film is set inside a dingy
hotel room and follows a damaged woman who
seems to be on the verge of a fresh start
after meeting a kind war vet.
When her new pal turns out to be one deeply
unhinged individual, what follows is a terrifying
descent into madness.
"I am the super mother bugggggggggggggg"
Friedkin keeps the action taut throughout,
making the proceedings extra stressful by
using expressionistic lighting, shooting his
stars in unflattering close-ups, and featuring
a handful of body horror scenes that will
definitely make your skin crawl.
Bug is essentially the cinematic equivalent
of poking at a raw nerve for a couple of hours,
but it's well worth the pain.